what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have a lot
of exciting news about thor love and
thunder including some awesome new
characters that are going to be coming
in the film we have a new look at some
lego sets that offer a really great look
at some of the characters coming and we
have a good idea of when to expect that
first teaser trailer for love and
thunder so a lot of exciting news to
break down today let's dive into it and
if you're new and you love marvel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so today's
news is actually coming straight from
marvel it's coming from marvel's website
marvel.com in which they have revealed
new lego sets to us that offer a lot of
information about the movie now lego
leagues are typically pretty common for
marvel movies so it just kind of looks
like marvel is getting a jump on the gun
here and posting it themselves before
leaks actually come out which is really
smart on their part and of course we're
not complaining because we get a better
look at the movie and there are actually
some pretty decent reveals here now
these aren't actually all lego some of
them are titan hero series and some of
them are fx series but all offer a much
better look at the movie including some
character costumes and some new
characters but let's start with thor's
costume because he has a brand new
outfit and it is really blue as you can
see it is really really different than
what we've seen him wear the last thing
we saw him wearing was well sweatpants
and a hoodie but before that in his
fight with thanos he was pretty much
wearing all black and a little bit of
silver now his suit looks to be
completely blue with gold on it and this
is really cool because it looks like
phase 4 seems to be the phase of comic
accurate costumes because this blue and
gold suit really resembles the first
thor costume ever designed by jack kirby
it's an iconic look and it looks like
we're finally getting that on the big
screen and then we get a look at jane
foster's thor who is labeled mighty thor
on a lot of these toy sets that we'll
talk about today now this is who she is
in the comics in the mighty thor
storyline when she picks up mjolnir she
becomes the goddess of thunder the
mighty thor so again sticking to comic
accurate things here and i really really
love it now her outfit isn't 100 comic
accurate like when they first introduced
the mighty thor but it looks actually
pretty dang good it looks a little bit
more modern which obviously of course in
the mcu you could expect that and we
actually get a much better look at both
of these costume designs on some other
toys that are released we have mjolnir
mighty fx mjolnir and a stormbreaker on
stormbreaker we get a better look at
thor's costume on the right there with
official promo art that they're using we
can see the suit really is blue and gold
it's got a ton of gold on it and for
jane foster's we can get a better look
at her suit here as well it looks to be
silver and like a reddish brownish color
but we get a pretty good look at her
helmet here which is going to be awesome
to see her wear and we also see that
mjolnir is repaired but it is still
cracked and even the toy itself looks
pretty cracked so yes mjolnir will be
rebuilt but it looks like it might have
some flaws in it now speaking of comic
accuracy the mighty thor is a story
where jane foster does become thor but
she has cancer and ultimately every time
that she picks up the hammer and
transforms into the mighty thor her
cancer gets worse and we know because
taiko atiti has revealed this to us that
this is going to be somewhat of the same
storyline we're going to get in thor
love and thunder jane foster is going to
have cancer so i'm sure much like in the
comics in the mcu becoming thor might
not be the best thing for her so we'll
have to see where the story goes now
here's something that i am super excited
about and i think a lot of people are
really going to love this we have our
first lego set reveal and marvel.com is
calling it the goat boat which is a
viking boat that is actually pulled by
two goats and this is something that i
am super excited to finally see in the
mcu thor's two goats tooth nasher and
tooth grinder in the comics thor can
summon both of these goats at will he
can also dismiss them at will and they
pull his mystical chariot of course thor
can fly with his hammer but tooth nasher
and tooth grinder can travel anywhere
within all of the realms they also help
thor transport things because yes he can
fly with his hammer but he can't exactly
carry a lot but these aren't just your
average goats they're the goats of goats
they actually have powers themselves one
they kind of eat everything including
people they both possess super strength
and they can actually damage mjolnir
that's how strong they are and like i
mentioned they can travel through all of
the realms at very high speeds and they
can do this on land or simply through
space so yes they can fly and if we look
at this picture of this lego set it does
look like they are pulling this viking
ship through space it actually looks
like they are traveling through
different dimensions if you can see all
the lights behind the ship here it
definitely looks like it's space travel
or it could actually be dimension travel
and since the multiverse is being
introduced a month before this movie
comes out in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness who knows where
they're going but you can see both goats
at the helm they're pulling the ship and
on the back of the boat here we can
actually see thor fighting gore in this
set the characters that are included as
said on the box are the mighty thor
which is jane foster four which is you
know our normal thor king valkyrie is
what it says here and of course she is
the king of asgard now not queen but
king korg of course is back as expected
and hoped for and then there is gore the
god butcher now what's really
interesting about this is that if you
look closely enough we can see on the
front of the ship it says a gear asgard
tours now there's two parts to this that
make it really really interesting one is
the first part agar now this is probably
the name of the boat and it makes sense
because in marvel comics a gear was the
god of the seas pretty much like neptune
except this is the norse god ager so it
would make sense that they named their
ship after the god of the sea but it
also says asgard tours now remember
asgard is now on earth and people are
aware of asgardians because thor is
actually quite famous we found this out
during thor ragnarok in the beginning
where people came up to him and asked to
take his picture and they also knew that
thor and jane broke up so thor is kind
of celebrity so it would make sense that
people would actually go to asgard to
kind of be tourists there and it looks
like asgard has kind of embraced it a
little bit after all they're probably
going to need a little bit of money at
least so that would probably be a pretty
decent way of making money giving tours
now all of this is fantastic it's great
to learn a lot about this movie and this
also means that the trailer shouldn't be
that far away doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness comes out a month
before thor love and thunder and they
gave us the first teaser trailer for
multiverse of madness about five months
before the movie is actually coming out
and that is kind of where we're at right
now with thor love and thunder we're
about five months away because it comes
out july 8th of 2022 so we're actually
less than five months away from the
release of thor love and thunder now if
you combine that fact with the fact that
marvel is now officially releasing
things like this toys legos official art
for the movie this means that promotion
for love and thunder is about to ramp up
this is an extremely good sign that
they're getting ready to release that
trailer and we just got the big
promotion for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness they released the
full official trailer during the super
bowl or i should say before the super
bowl but that was the one thing that it
looked like marvel studios was waiting
on because they weren't going to give us
a trailer for love and thunder before we
got the official one for doctor strange
but we have that now promotions are
beginning to start and we have less than
five months until the movie comes out so
i would expect the first teaser trailer
relatively soon if marvel sticks to the
same thing they've been doing we
hopefully get it within a month but as
always if i hear anything about when to
expect that first teaser trailer i'll of
course do a video on it letting
everybody know in the meantime let me
know what you all think about these new
reveals through these new toys what do
you think of the new costumes and what
do you think about tooth nasher and
tooth grinder coming to the mcu let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the mcu for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof